it's been a difficult week for rukia's
family her husband was recently arrested
for marrying her when she was barely 14
years old his mother has fallen sick
leaving Rukia to care for her and their
daughter
there are lots of problems my daughter
stays hungry I don't have money to buy
medicines for my mother-in-law we
depended on my husband who worked at a
Rice Mill
Assam stayed in India's Northeast is
cracking down on child marriage in the
last two weeks authorities have arrested
hundreds of people including Grooms
parents clerics and Priests child
marriage has been linked with poor
maternal health and high infant
mortality Assam state has one of the
highest rates of child marriage in India
nearly one in six women here have had
children when they were just teenagers
that number is higher in rural areas
where there are strong patriarchal
biases and few opportunities for women
during birth the government says its aim
is to improve Women's Health Eris is a
drastic action just to make people
realize the fault the mistake they have
done for so many years ages decades the
stiff has to be a social movement we
have to be aware we have to stop the
child marriage at any cost
women are demanding their husbands
release saying there's no one to earn
and feed the family most of the people
arrested are from poor marginalized
communities there are growing calls to
instead improve girls education and
focus on gender equality there are
different ways to address this problem
the Crackdown was sudden unannounced
that's why it came as a kind of a shock
at the community level you know
and that is why to even add the impact
of the Crackdown the way the impact of
the Crackdown also needs to be addressed
police have registered more than 4 000
cases jails are filling up and people
are being shifted to a Detention Center
built for undocumented migrants the
government says it'll rehabilitate
families but some child bribes like
Rukia say they'll be happier and better
off with their husbands back home
Assam Northeast India